au début de la semaine encore Davy
Johnston parlait d'avenir la prochaine
page de mon travail mais plutôt que
d'aller plus loin il s'arrête ici mon
objectif était d'aider à croître la
confiance dans nos institutions
démocratiques et créent-ils dans sa
lettre de démission je constate que
compte tenu du climat hautement partisan
entourant ma nomination et mon travail
mon rôle a eu l'effet opposé la décision
qu'il a annoncé aujourd'hui était
inévitable il n'a pas jamais réussi à
gagner la confiance de la majorité des
députés de la Chambre depuis sa
nomination David Johnston n'a cessé
d'être sous le feu des critiques
un rapporteur est-ce que ça vient avec
une cape et une épée ironisait pierre
poillière elle est partie d'opposition
ont gagné est-ce que c'est la taille de
Monsieur Johnson qu'ils ont eu ou bien
la nomination de Justin Trudeau je pense
que ça cause aussi un problème pour le
Premier ministre dès le départ c'est lié
avec la Fondation Trudeau l'avait
ditquée aux yeux des parties
d'opposition beaucoup de rigueur à cause
de sa proximité du Premier ministre il y
a pas pu faire son travail comme il y
aurait dessus le faire ces derniers
appuis ce sont désistés après qu'il a
conclu dans son premier rapport qu'une
enquête indépendante n'était pas
nécessaire c'est vraiment c'est quand tu
dis que le repas et l'apparence aussi
d'un conflit d'une feuille qui faisait
une sorte éventuellement que je pense il
a vu la raison pour lesquelles les
parlementaires votaient un très grand
majorité pour que il démissionne
party le problème de l'ingérence
chinoise demeure appelle la politologue
Geneviève Tellier première étape c'est
de d'enlever la partie zannerie de
commencer à dire bon ben qu'est-ce qu'on
fait collectivement en tant que député
[Musique]
les sceptiques mais son passage n'aura
pas été tout à fait vaincu ce député
bloqué on a perdu du temps mais c'est il
faut quand même réaliser que ça nous a
conforté vraiment dans notre position et
là le premier reste pas le choix il y a
pas question qu'on vive dans ce film là
une deuxième fois c'est pourquoi selon
nous c'est une enquête publique vraiment
indépendante va vraiment aider à faire
toute la lumière dans ces lettres de
démission il va de dernier conseil à
Justin Trudeau en l'encourageant à
nommer une personne dotée d'expérience
en sécurité nationale pour poursuivre le
travail jusqu'à la toute fin il leur a
tenté de recentrer l'attention sur
l'ingérence chinoise même si pour cela
il a fallu qu'il reconnaisse qu'il
faisait lui-même davantage partie du
problème que de la solution ici Valérie
Gamache Radio-Canada
Ottawa